the Labour prioritized the LGBTQ vote
and which alienated the Pacific Islander
vote yes and it was all because of a
rugby player yeah well I mean this is
this is what led to the shied I am
reasonably satisfied now having done a
booth by booth analysis in two of the
seats that Labour lost and one seat that
it very nearly lost what Queensland said
that it very nearly lost seats with a
very significant concentration of
Pacific Islander voters and I mean you
won't know what they are you won't know
what they are Pacific Islanders are
people from you know sort of Vanuatu who
cook islands in New Zealand from Hawaii
Tonga Fiji there lots and lots and lots
of them in Australia going back over
over a hundred years Pacific Islanders
were brought often forcibly to Australia
in the 19th century to cut sugar cane
and they were referred to this is quite
a vulgar word in Australia now but it's
historically accurate they were referred
to as kanakas and they were a form of
indentured labour so there is a
significant going back I don't know that
we're but I am now worried now is just
me getting what I used to call as a
teacher
SBS which is sweaty back syndrome back
we can just feel this oh you haven't
dropped their bond but you know it's it
that was the term that used to be used
it's not used now and it's not as rude
as the n-bomb and there are certainly
ruder words in Australia than that as
Australia is a significant Pacific
Islander population and the Pacific
Islands the missionaries who went there
were almost uniquely successful compared
to everywhere else in the world and
they're a mixture of Pentecostal
Presbyterian methodist uniting you know
sort of all different varieties of
protestant they're not catholic they're
all varieties of protestant and they're
quite traditionally conservative and
religious
and they have this very similar moral
values to Muslims except as i i've
pointed out to a few people except that
they're completely monogamous obviously
because that's part of christianity and
israel philau who was the rugby player
in question put up on his Instagram a
homophobic I don't do Instagram except
for pictures of my cats I'm not sure how
it works a homophobic mean basically
that among other things said that gay
people were going to go to hell and of
course he's the best rugby player in
Australia he is a multi-millionaire from
being a rugby players enormous ly gifted
and this caused an enormous stink
because he'd violated rugby Australia's
social media policy and so there was
this ongoing an enormous stink that just
dragged on and on and on because you
have these sporting bodies they have
their own internal rule requirements in
terms of dispute resolution and so on
and so forth and then you can go through
the courts and then you can go through
an employment tribunal and all of this
kind of thing and all the different
stages of this over a conservative
Christian rugby player was just going on
at the same time as the election
campaign and an organisation called the
Australian Christian Lobby did what I
used to do for my senator when I was
working for him did private polling
about the effect of the treatment of
Israel Folau was having not only among
Pacific Islanders but just among
Christians more generally and it soon
became clear that even many people who
were not a particularly Christian were
looking at it from the perspective of
proud sports people Australia as a proud
sporting nation has got ot a sporting
significant sporting heritage it's taken
very seriously in the country and
Australians are very good at sport and I
hope the country wins numbers of Olympic
medals out of all proportion to its tiny
population every Olympics and all of
this kind of thing so a lot of people
were just looking at the Israel for our
situation and going
is to do with his ability to play rugby
how and why do you even care and even a
couple of other people who either sort
of X Wallabies and X Waratahs which is
his stateside New South Wales Waratahs
we're saying we it's not just Israel
Folau you'll have to get rid of every
Pacific Islander in the Australian rugby
team because that's what they were all
like they just don't necessarily stick
it on their Instagram but that's what
they all think they're conservative
Christians are you going to get rid of
all of the Pacific Islanders out of the
Australian rugby team and if you do
isn't that a bit racist because it's
this it's the same argument that you
have with Islam over here if you start
picking on people for having really
really conservative religious views and
most of those people are Muslim and most
of those people are brown on you might
mean it but it can start to have a
racist a racial affect in Australia it's
it's Pacific Islanders if you start
chucking every Pacific Islander out of
the rugby team for having conservative
religious views they're gonna lose every
game we surrender to New Zealand might
as well say that but you're also you're
getting rid of all of the brown players
in your team and you'll finish up with a
team of only white players and Australia
probably would be quiet
no man no matter how you dress that up
that's going to look bad so a lot of
people what you're saying is a lot of
people felt that what we might call the
progressive left had gone too far in the
way that Israel was dealt with yes and
as a consequence of that and some air in
some electrics it transferred in it
transfer I'm reasonably satisfied now
having done a booth by booth analysis
that it transferred into votes for the
coalition or at least preferences to the
coalition they might have put number one
for you know a local for a protest party
and there's lots of those but they've
their preferences flowed to the
coalition
[Music]